- [Narrator] This is the F-16 fighter jet,
developed by the US with a
number of European partners.
And this is the Su-35, the
Russian equivalent being deployed
in the Ukraine War.
Kyiv says it wants 200 western jets,
such as the Eurofighter Typhoon,
F-16, or Swedish Gripen,
so they can dominate the skies.
- We have freedom, give
us wings to protect it.
- [Narrator] And while the US has said
it won't give fighter jets to Kyiv,
the UK and some European
countries are now considering
sending combat aircraft.
- Any decision to send or
to supply combat aircraft
would inevitably be significant.
- [Narrator] So what
capabilities could western jets
give Ukraine?
And how do they compare to
the main Russian jet deployed
in the war?
(jet engine roaring)
First, let's look at why western
jets are important to Kyiv.
So far, neither Ukraine nor Russia
has achieved air superiority.
That's an air force's ability
to take control of the sky,
stopping anybody other than themselves
from entering a particular airspace.
At the start of the war,
Moscow had nearly 1,200
combat-capable aircraft,
according to the IISS Think Tank.
That was far more than Kyiv's inventory
of around 120 aging Soviet-era aircraft.
- So the challenge for Ukraine
is its combat air inventory
is increasingly difficult to maintain.
In a combat environment, you really need
as many of your aircraft
available and on the flight line
as you can have, almost round the clock.
- [Narrator] To avoid
using their limited jets,
Ukraine has focused on its air defenses,
shooting down over a hundred
Russian planes and helicopters
with surface-to-air missiles.
This has made Moscow
reluctant to send its own jets
beyond the frontline.
Analysts say it's mainly used
the long-range capabilities
of its air force to strike
Ukrainian targets from afar.
- So one of the challenges
the Ukrainians have is
that their Soviet-era air-to-air missiles,
particularly the
beyond-visual-range weapons
don't have anything like
the engagement range
that the Russian combat
aircraft do at the moment.
- [Narrator] Experts say
western jets would allow Kyiv
to counter Russia's air force directly,
changing the balance
of power in the skies.
So, let's look at the specifics
of how these jets operate
on the battlefield.
Russia's Su-35 is larger
than the aircraft Ukraine
could receive from its allies,
allowing it to carry a
bigger weapon's payload.
It's also equipped with a passive sensor
that can spot opposing jets
without being detected itself.
Paired with long-range missiles
that can fire at targets
over 60 miles away,
analysts say it's had a
distinct advantage in medium
and long-range aerial encounters
against Ukraine's current
inventory of Soviet-era aircraft.
But western jets, such as
the F-16, would come equipped
with advanced medium-range missiles,
including the American AIM-120.
Analysts say these weapons
could level the playing field,
allowing Ukraine to more
effectively challenge
Russia's air force in medium
and long-range encounters.
But when it comes to air power,
it's not just the systems that matter.
The person piloting the
jet is just as important.
Experts say Ukraine's pilots
will need extensive training
for up to a year to use any
western aircraft effectively.
- You can't just take somebody out
of a Soviet-design combat
aircraft and expect them
to be able to fight to the
same level the next day.
Even for an experienced fast-jet pilot,
there is a period of
conversion and just to get used
to the aircraft, its
displays, how it handles,
and then you also gotta learn
how to fight the aircraft.
- [Narrator] So the UK has agreed
to start training Ukrainian pilots,
as Kyiv continues to press its
allies into providing jets.
Western governments are nervous
that providing the weapons,
which could be used to
hit targets inside Russia,
could escalate the war.
(missile firing)
But analysts say that any model of jet
would complement the arsenal of weaponry,
including HIMARS and tanks,
that Kyiv is already
receiving from its allies.
(tense music)